hey Tony to copal here and guess what
I do not have the flu the question is
how long is that gonna last though
because flu season is here and the CDC
is recommending that people start
getting their annual flu shot I hate
shots dr. Turner ulla is with me in the
turret of green room to discuss how you
can start preparing for flu season and
some of the misconceptions out there
about the vaccine one thing it's not a
misconception is it involves a needle it
does we can get to that well we're a
nasal mist oh yes so they are
recommending this year that people who
are 2 to 49 years old can get the nasal
mist if they want as opposed to the
needle so so I want to talk about the
vaccines but but pre vaccine or prior to
the vaccine what are the other things
you can do to avoid getting the flu well
so typical precautions hand-washing
staying home if you're sick so you don't
affect your colleagues sneezing or
coughing into a tissue you know all of
the typical things that we talk about to
prevent spread of disease is it better
if you have to sneeze to use your hands
or like the crook of your elbow I see I
see this one a lot if you're gonna wash
your hands right away it's probably five
but so yes usually people do this but
the best is the tissue okay yeah wash
your hands after so washing hands all
day around flu season very helpful and
and would you consider the flu vaccine
an optional thing or just everyone
should get it well the recommendation by
the CDC and others is that every one six
months and older should get the flu
vaccine the only exception to that is
really people who've had some sort of
severe life-threatening allergy to the
flu vaccine or a component of the flu
vaccine or for those who are younger
than six months does it cost much so in
some cases it's free certainly if you
have insurance certain places will offer
it for free or it can cost up to about
forty or fifty dollars but worth the
investment you would say absolutely
worth the investment I think a lot of
people think flu is just like the cold
no big deal I get sick I get better but
it is associated with complications
things like ear infections sinus
infections pneumonia and obviously death
you know last year in the adult
population anywhere between thirty and
sixty thousand deaths 135 pediatric
deaths hundreds of thousands of
hospitalizations and for people who have
chronic diseases like heart disease or
lung disease or diabetes I mean this can
really exacerbate those problems so if
you have heart disease for example six
times more likely to have a heart attack
hour you know after you've had the flu
so really important for those
populations especially also to get the
flu vaccine well the flu comes in this
seasonal wave and I know there are
different ideas about why it comes in
that way but you know I'm thinking
Australia's on the other side of the
world it's already been winter and flu
season there do we can we learn anything
from that flu season about what flu
season might be coming here so the
experts always say we can't really take
what happened there and absolutely apply
it to what the prediction will be for
this year we don't really know but it
does give us a sense and we know that
this past year in Australia they did see
more cases of the flu than they ever
have in the past five years so lots and
lots of hospitalizations there it did
seem like the vaccine that they've
created this year was a better match for
the flu in Australia so maybe there's
hope that it will be a good match for
our flu season as well these days
vaccines unjustifiably but vaccines do
make people nervous is there anything
about the flu vaccine that isn't risk we
should know about and also some people
say I got the shot and now I feel kind
of wiped out for the day yeah kind of
like a mini illness from it I mean some
people can so the people who there's
really only 1% of people who are going
to have some sort of severe reaction to
the flu shot for everybody else is
typically soreness at the site where
they give you the shot maybe some mild
systemic symptoms like I feel a little
feverish or muscle aches and those
usually pass within a couple of days so
there's really no reason to avoid it I
know there's a lot of myths around the
flu vaccine but you can't get the flu
from the flu vaccine some people say I
got the flu vaccine and I got the flu
anyway it takes about two weeks for you
to build up antibodies so if you got the
flu vaccine and then you got exposed in
those two weeks guess what you might get
the flu and if you're if you're
completely allergic not only the flu but
two needles so the nasal mist we've had
it before last year it actually was not
recommended but they've made some
adjustments and they this year it is
recommended for those two to 49 years
old all right that's good anything else
people should know important thing is
that really even if you get the flu and
it's not the perfect match for the
strain that's in the vaccine the vaccine
can prevent the flu that you get from
bearing as serious right so you're less
likely to develop complications the
symptoms you get may be less severe so
it's really a
important to get it regardless of
whether it ends up being a perfect match
a lot of people worry about that all
right I began this segment flu free and
if I follow these tips I shall remain so
end of October you got to get it before
the end of October ideally all right
check out social media for the video of
me getting my flu shot it's coming out
Tara thank you very much I appreciate it
for more tips on preventing the flu go
to CBS this morning calm
that's on the computer